good morning believe nation today we're
going to talk about the habits of
successful people rule number one is my
personal favorite and I'd love to know
which one you guys like the best and as
always guys as you're listening if you
hear something that really really
resonates with you please leave it in
the comments below and put quotes around
it so other people can be inspired and
also as you write things down you're
much more likely to keep it in here as
well enjoy the power of 21 and so what
I've been telling you to get that gold
get that dream and I'm just been telling
you driving and driving and driving and
driving what I've been talking about is
consistency and for some of you for real
for real you'll never have it
you'll never be it you'll never do it
because you don't have any consistency
you listen to me you're killing me and
you're killing yourself you start and
you stop and you start and you stop and
then you start and you stop and your
goal you got to own the walls you got to
Bentley on the wall you got the gated
community on the wall you got the degree
on the wall but the problem is you keep
starting and stopping and starting
stopping and all I'm asking you to do
for me as I'm asking for some
consistency all right so I'm time I sell
our 21 are you here when I'm telling you
I'm talking about doing something for 21
straight days now it may it may not work
I remember when I first did this the
first thing I started my boy hollering
Hill he gave me a book called book of
Proverbs right he told me to read like a
book of Proverbs a day for 21 days like
he like he just got to have it he's for
real we started with reading proverbs
something real simple but he said he if
you can if you can do something for 21
days like you'll never have to think
about it I don't know if you caught what
I told you this morning I woke up at 3
o'clock this morning three o'clock burnt
out tired like you know II I can't do it
I just boom went back to sleep
boom three minutes later my body woke me
up what am I saying you I'm telling you
consistency habits my body like yo he I
don't know what you're doing I don't
know what you think you're doing but we
don't do that sleep is for something get
up I listen to me not my mind my body
kicked in and said get up we're talking
about consistency and so I read the book
for 21 straight days right and I started
doing other stuff I said we gonna
exercise for 21 days I just started
trying to do stuff for 21 days to see if
I can do it and what I discovered is for
real and I'ma be honest which I did 14
days then I started all over again I
said at this time I did 16 day now I
started all over again and I did 18 days
and I thought all over again and I did
21 some stuff I can do 21 straight days
some stuff I got to start and stop and
start and stop and start but when you
get to 21 there's power and consistency
what do you see is a some of the common
habits of these successful people
outside of believing in the best and
people like you talked about not being
as critical you know being flexible
mentally whatever what if some of the
other habits I I think that a most
important attribute of a good leader is
somebody who listens well and be and you
know a good leader you know knows what
he's what he thinks so there's no point
in you know especially what you think
through your team and what you need to
do is learn learn from your team learn
from your customers listen I'm a great
believer in writing things down so if
I'm having a meeting and and people are
coming up with lots of ideas and if I
don't write things down I know I'm only
going to remember you know a couple of
things the next day and often quite a
lot of my meetings that you know at the
bar at 1:00 in the morning and I know
definitely I'm not going to remember the
next day what my staff have told me so
again you know write write things down
and then the next day you can pull out
your list and you can get you know set
about sorting things out and if I'm
flying on the Virgin airline you know
I'll meet all the passengers are listen
to them write things down or meet these
staff listen to them write things down
and sometimes it's tiny little things
but it's those tiny little things that
make for
exceptional company over an average
company so you know here here in America
you know Virgin America we started as a
few years ago I think the reason it
consistently gets voted the best airline
of states is because you know we listen
we get all those little details right
and so you know so that our customers
are happy and you know our customers are
happy your staff are happy your staff
smile and and you know it's quite rare
on airlines to have staff that smile but
they do smile because they because the
customers are happy and everybody's
happy yeah
so listening is the key I should mention
one thing about reading it was at the
library here at Columbia so I wish I
spent probably more time than any other
soon
I lived there practically but and I
pulled the book out there have to be
who's in American that told me something
about my professor Benjamin ran there
and then I looked up and I went to
library and I said I want to learn more
about this because I learned this over
here that changed my whole life
you know we owned I go down because of
that librarian directing me some other
book and then following through on that
it's the chance I read about one fifth
to pace the bill does but still spend
five or six hours a day reading I mean
it just you can learn so much I pretty
well biography just be able to live the
lives of these people live Ben's
exploded you can see them so
extraordinary the lessons and both you
know the Scourge much they say it's just
everything about it so I did you can't
get enough of reading had done I think
my life would be very unbalanced by most
people's definition since I worked quite
a lot
and you know I've probably put in
between 80 and 100 hours a week of work
which is which is a lot and yeah so and
then but most of my remaining waking
hours I spent with my kids so that's
that's my life I would say it's roughly
unbalanced and then just work like hell
I mean you just have to put in you know
80 hour 80 100 hour weeks every week and
then that work that's all those things
improve the odds of success okay
I mean if other people are putting in 40
hour work weeks and you're putting in
100 hour work weeks then even if you're
doing the same thing you know that in
one year you will achieve what they
achieve you will achieve in four months
what it takes them a year to achieve I'm
lucky to know a lot of famous people
Bill Gates Warren Buffet the Jack Welch
Larry Page Mark Zuckerberg I know all of
that I would like to share with you that
those people the difference between
those people and other people they are
always optimistic for the future they
never complain they always try to solve
the problems of the others and I think
where is the opportunity the opportunity
lie always lies in the place where
people complain some people sit there
complained you think if I can solve that
complaint that's the opportunity that's
what I did don't complain let the other
people complain those people complain
those people who still and do not always
say well I don't have think about how
you can make things different use your
own brain to think you tried to get into
three colleges each time they rejected
you now I tried there is a examination
that young people if you want to go
universe
you have the taste take the examinations
so I food a three times by a lot of Phil
I feel for funny things that I food a
key primary school tests for two times
and I filled like three times for the
middle school cook middle schools and
you were never believed in in Hangzhou
my city there is only one middle school
that lasts only one year it was changed
from primary school middle school
degrees our graduates of ours our Alice
ku no universe you know middle school
except us because we were too bad I
would become a bit aggressive
what effect did it have though being
rejected well I think we have to get
used to it
we're not that good even today we still
have a lot of people reject us I think
when I in the graduate from University
and before you know for three years I
tried fill in the universities so I
applied jobs of 30 times I reject it I
went for a police if you know you're not
good I went to you know even the KFC
when KFC came to China birthday party 24
people went for the job 23 people
accepted I was only regarding
and we went for please five people all
of them accepted I was the only guy deny
respectful people so to me he turned
down rejected oh by the way I told you
that I would I apply for Harvard for ten
times rejected I know if you reject our
sorry now ten times you wrote them and
said I'd like to come to Harvard
yeah and then I told my so some deaf
could go teach there buddy here's what
I've created from my life and anyone who
knows succeeded I'm a seventeen year old
kid from Azusa California with no real
education other than self education with
no background with parents that did
their best all of them
with no money but I did one thing I love
people and I had an enormous demand I
made upon myself and I sculpted my mind
and my emotions to get me to do whatever
it would take to achieve and to
contribute but to do that I did it by
using my body and changing my focus I
did it by putting myself in a keep
physiology and using what I call
incantations can you train yourself to
believe something yes or no absolutely
how many have ever made the fatal
mistake at going to Disneyland or Disney
World and while you're there made the
fatal mistake of going to a ride called
it's a small world after all what
happens for about a week after you're
out of that damn place you're still
singing this thing in your hand and 24
languages right let me tell you
something how many of you have things
when you want to go achieve them and
this part of you voice goes not going to
happen or forget it I'm gonna go to
voices sometimes interrupts that good
pattern say what you want to do is train
a new one so starting when I was 17 I
started doing incantations not
affirmations affirmation you'll have the
Olympia Manthey event Mme what's the
problem
you haven't changed your what your what
physiology if you don't change your
physiology you won't get anything so in
in cam cases not only you speak it but
you embody what you're saying with all
the intensity you can and you do it with
enough repetitions that it sticks in
your head like it's a small world now
the conversation your head is always the
same and it gives you what you want so
use your body and your voice so 17 years
ago I started doing things I was working
for Jim Rohn this speaker I was 17 years
old I had long hair minestrone soup acne
on my face and I was trying to call on
Bear Stearns type of people and convince
them why they should go to this man
seminar be more successful I was drawn a
1968 Volkswagen ride earned at $40 a
week as a janitor the only way I did it
was parked far from the building and
then go in and I love people I believe
what I put myself in state I was able to
influence people that were far more
successful I was at the time I will do
something that I still do backstage and
have done for 23 years because I don't
hope I'm going to be
good state I demand it so I do an
incantation using my whole body I now
command my subconscious mind to directly
helping as many people's possible life
today to better their lives
I give me the strength the emotion the
persuasion the humor the brevity
whatever a day you surely feel and get
these people to change their lives now I
would do that literally driving in my
Volkswagen to a meeting in LA on the
freeway for 40 minutes people in mind
screaming about my lungs they're going I
know he's a serial killer I know he is
but by the time I entered that room when
two people meet if there's a rapport the
person who's most certain will always
influence the other person and I was
totally certain and they were trying to
get revved up to certainty do you agree
with this yes or no I do another one
because I was poor I changed my mindset
I kept doing things but I never got
beyond it
I'd say God's love just circulating in
my life as well as close to me in
avalanches of abundance all my needs
desires and goals are met
instantaneously by infinite intelligence
for I'm one with God and God is
everything and I would imagine the
abundance in my life and I would feel so
grateful year later I went to making
$38,000 year to make $1,000,000 and one
year I've started and I'm still not
great at this either these are always
works in progress when it's not the
thing that comes most natural to you but
I think what I've been doing well lately
is I've been giving more honest critical
direct to people's face feedback you
know I tend to be a little bit softer
I'm much more of a honey over vinegar
guy but you know between our former
managing director Kelly and AJ the very
straight shooter operators they've used
me along I definitely evolved in that
category I'm definitely better at it I
still want to have deal with a ton of
empathy and and heart and soul but
shooting it straight is bringing more
value to me and it's just speeding up
the process of victory can't have a CEO
I wouldn't say I'm not I'm very decisive
but boy you know delivering bad news
does not come natural to me and I don't
love it so building infrastructure
around me and then doing it myself has
been an important evolution that I've
done much better being immediate and
I've done a Wine Library and what that's
given me is the thing that a lot of you
know that I value which is speed
those two thank you guys so much for
watching I made this beauty because and
money in jar asked me to if there's a
topic you like me to cover in the next
edition to believe life please leave it
down in the comments below and I'll see
what I can do I'd also love to know what
did you learn from this video what was
the most important takeaway that you're
going to apply to your life or your
business immediately now that you saw
this clip please leave it down the
comments below if you have anything
you'd like to add a tip a suggestion for
other people to be more successful
habits that you feel maybe we missed
leave it down again in the comments I'm
really curious to see what you have to
say finally I want to give a quick shout
to esteban serrano thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book your one
word really really really really means a
lot to me and I hope you enjoying the
read so thank you guys again for
watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one where it is much love
have an amazing day and I'll see you
soon